ever since the Empire Strikes Back hit
cinemas 34 years ago Star Wars games
have been obsessed with recreating the
Battle of Hoth there are so many cool
moments that we want to play flying a
snow speeder and tripping up an imperial
walker defending Echo Base from the
ground even commanding an 8080 itself
but can a single Star Wars game even
capture all of this what do they need to
pick and choose which sides of the
battle to depict which one does it best
find out as we look over three decades
of Star Wars games that have depicted
the rebel alliances most catastrophic
defeat beginning with the very first
Star Wars game ever made
Star Wars The Empire Strikes Back for
the Atari 2600 came out two years after
the film and it actually skipped a new
hope entirely to strap you straight into
the Battle of Hoth the game was so basic
that you didn't have harpoons and tow
cables so you just have to fly laps
around each Imperial Walker and blast
through its armor in pursuit of a high
score this score attack focus meant was
actually impossible to win which is
totally appropriate because the Battle
of Hoth is where the good guys actually
lose next up is the 1985 Empire Strikes
Back arcade game from Atari there's a
meteorite round area this time you
piloted a snow speeder in first person
and in stunning vector graphics you also
got to shoot tow cables at the 80-82
legs to trip them up but they went down
instantly and without needing to fly
circles around them so it's not exactly
the most authentic recreation of the
film that digitized speech is pretty
sweet though the waters with you that is
this I'm sure Skywalker is with them
seven years later Star Wars games were
still being conservative with their
titles but it was for a good reason
the nes platformer Star Wars The Empire
Strikes Back featured levels from the
whole film rather than one particular
scene still its Battle of Hoth sequence
diverged from platforming to
side-scrolling snow speeder combat
directly inspired by the first Atari
game but this time your snow speeder
could crash into the foreground and
you'd continue on foot if you reach
another 8080 you could grapple up to its
underbelly and destroy it with a grenade
just like in the film a few months later
came Super Empire Strikes Back for the
Super Nintendo
everything was souped up the graphics
the difficulty and especially the snow
speeder level the game rendered Hoth as
a quasi 3d open space reminiscent of
Star Fox and it was the first time you
needed to fly your snow speeder around
an 80-82 entangle its legs in your toe
cable but actually accomplishing this
whilst grappling with the mode 7 engines
loose interpretation of depth perception
was no easy task
next is an on-rails shooter and one of
the earliest games with full motion
video
Star Wars rebel assault
ah key one good to have you on board
because this Battle of Hoth was
pre-rendered you weren't so much
whizzing around the Imperial walkers as
you were watching a fuzzy film when
aiming a barely responsive crosshair
over the footage with no tow cables you
could only destroy the 88 es by
endlessly blasting their holes with
lasers rebel assault actually made
playing the Battle of Hoth rather boring
shadows of the Empire had the opposite
problem its first level set during the
Battle of Hoth was so good that the rest
of the game seemed dull by comparison
piloting a snow speeder in the games
fully 3d environment for the first time
was fantastic to take down the Imperial
walkers you had to fight circles around
them with your tow cable while the
camera shifted to this really awkward
cinematic perspective those super Empire
Strikes Back did this first it wasn't
until this game 16 years after the
release of the film that tripping up an
8080 finally felt satisfied
two years after shadows of the Empire's
freeform flight Star Wars trilogy arcade
returned to on-rails
snow speeding this was the first game
where the 80 ATS had location damage as
in the film they could be destroyed by
shooting a weak point in their neck you
were also told to go into attack pattern
Delta
several times
purely because it's a line from the film
I mean to this day I have no idea what
attack that and Delta actually is
attack pattern Delta go down the same
year saw the release of rogue squadron
an entire game inspired by the Hoth
level from shadows of the Empire your
your heartburn calculate on perhaps for
this reason Rogue Squadron saved its own
bat warthog for an unlockable bonus
level it played slightly differently
with type canyons to fly through and an
even more awkward tow cable camera but
when he had shadows of the empire
available on the same system it was
probably a good move not to focus too
much on the Battle of Hoth again people
out let her go another victory for rogue
squad three years in one console
generation later came Rogue Squadron to
rogue leader rebel transports preparing
for evacuation the GameCubes greater
grunt meant you could have more Imperial
walkers in an even wider expanse of snow
rogue leader also finally got the scale
of the 88 he's right these things were
huge and actually looked like they could
crush a snow speeder under one of their
enormous stomping feet with rogue leader
it finally felt like we had played the
definitive Battle of Hoth
so where do you go from there
for Rogue Squadron three rebel strike
factor five got you out of your snow
speeder
Pogo Walker you ran around as Luke
Skywalker shooting snowtroopers and
riding a tauntaun but you could also
grapple up to an 80 ATS underbelly and
throw a grenade in through a series of
QuickTime events
watch our pros ETA trees try to take
them down
yeah it was pretty bad down there it was
Star Wars Battlefront 2 that finally
married this on foot gameplay with the
vehicular combat that this scene is
remembered for this is battlefield style
combined arms warfare in the Star Wars
universe which means battlefront 2
presented the most fully featured
intense an immersive depiction of the
Battle of Hoth plus being a multiplayer
game you finally got to pilot an
Imperial Walker and shoot down pesky
snowspeeders Battlefront 2 also added
the ability to play as Luke and Darth
Vader so you can recreate everything
from the assault against the Imperial
walkers these guys are easy to the
destruction of the shield generator
through to Vader's storming of Echo Base
itself
25 years after the Empire Strikes Back
hit cinemas
it took a game like battlefront to to
finally realize what participating in
the Battle of Hoth could be like with
the battlefront license now in dices
hands and a deeper look at the game in
store for III this year we could be set
to realize all over again
why Star Wars games haven't been able to
leave this frigid planet behind